[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette émission qui se
s'intitule de la prison à l'entreprise
et qui est consacré au au travail en
détention un travail qui présente des
avantages puisque ça permet une
meilleure réinsertion des des détenus et
ça peut aussi présenter des avantages
pour les entreprises c'est donc un
contrat qu'on pourra appeler gagnant
gagnant on va en pararler tout au long
de cette émission avec Isabelle Laurenz
bonjour bonjour vous êtes la directrice
adjointe du centre pénitentiaire de bois
d'Arc où a été lancé d'ailleurs le par
le Garde des saau le Tour de France on
le verra tout à l'heure du du travail en
détention centre pénitentiaire
pourquoiil existe deux régimes de
détention au centre pénitentiaire don
des Yvelines on dit boisarsy parce que
c'est un elle est implantée dans la
ville de boisarcy mais c'est le centre
pénitentiaire des ivelines et donc on a
un quartier maison d'arrêt et un
quartier centre de semiberté c'est pour
ça qu'on appelle ça un centre
pénitentiaire alors maison d'arrêt alors
la maison d'arrêt c'est ce qu'on appelle
un peu la garee de triage c'està-dire
que toutes les personnes écrouées en
premier lieu arrivent en maison d'arrêt
donc avant le jugement avant alors avant
le jugement et aussi après le
jugement soit les courtes peines qui
vont rester à la maison d'arrêt soit des
moyennes et long PE qui vont attendre en
maison d'arrêt le temps d'être affecté
en établissement pour peine d'accord et
les centres se liberté c'est pour les
personnes détenues qui sont sous mesure
d'aménagement de peine donc une
semiliberté ordonnée par un juge
d'application des peines très bien
Stéphane runif bonjour bonjour vous êtes
tici vous êtes capitaine vous êtes
responsable du travail et de la
formation professionnelle des détenus he
c'est ça tout à fait et donc voilà c'est
très important d'avoir votre votre rendu
sur sur sur
évidemmentah l'avantage pour les détenu
de pouvoir travailler et et l'avantage
aussi pour leur réinsertion euh Alain
CISS bonjour bonjour vous êtes directeur
général ressources humaines et finances
de de
prongin prongin alors c'est une
entreprise qui est située àinti l'école
l'école qui
est exactement c'est la d'où l'intérêt
de de travailler d'avoir ouvert
l'atelier qu'on a ouvert sur
boisarcy c'est une société qui a plus de
50 ans d'existence française dans le
secteur de la défense et du et du civil
puisque nous concevons fabriquons des
détecteurs de gaz chimique et
bactériologique et maintenant on offre
une on a une offre beaucoup plus étendue
pour tous les
systèmes de détection de détection et
c'est intéressant parce que vous n direz
comment une entreprise qui est justement
la défense la défense nationale
peut employer justement des détenus on
pourrait pas penser a priori comme ça
qu' des secteurs qui sont qui sont
interdit mais ça sera intéressant
justement d'en parler avec vous
euh Alban bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur de latigip c'est l'agence du
travail d'intérêt général et de
l'insertion professionnelle et donc vous
vous occupez évidemment des du travail
des détenus et puis Éric grimillon
bonjour bonjour euh vous êtes
responsable de production en charge des
relations de la coordination euh pour
prengin de avec l'atelier de boisarc
c'estàd que voilà c'est c'est vous qui
allez euh notamment dans dans la prison
de boisarcy euh je suis chef de projet
sur ce travail qui est donné en milieu
carcéral sur boisarcy en fait hein parce
que je suis directeur adjoint des
opérations chez pran et donc sur la la
création de de de partenariat on va dire
avec bois d'arcille donc je suis chargé
en tant que chef de projet de pouvoir
mettre en place du travail euh minutieux
précis avec le centre de bois d'Arc quoi
c'està dire qu'il faut recruter et
former je recrute maintenant il y a des
une nouvelle instauration qui a été
donnée par le Garde des saau le ministre
monsieur Dupont moriti qui a créé aussi
un une nouvelle forme de travail en fait
et donc maintenant ce sont déjà j'ai
toujours appelé ce personnel des
opérateurs prangin je refuse un autre
terme en fait et puis maintenant je ce
sont les salariés brangeins pour pour
moi en fait voilà alors avant de de
commencer à
expliquer d'abord comment se déroule ce
ce travail en prison et l'intérêt de ce
travail je vous propose de de retrouver
il y a quelques mois le garde des saau
Éric Dupont Moretti est venu à boisarci
pour lancer justement le tour de de
France du du
travail en prison
euh on a était on était sur place on va
vous voir d'ailleurs vous étiez là aussi
àinissé je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
le ministre de la Justice en visite à la
prison de Bois d'Arcy fervent défenseur
du travail en prison Éric Dupont Moretti
est venu présenter le contrat d'emploi
pénitentiaire entré en vigueur en début
d'année ce contrat il est utile pour le
détenu qui se forme et qui sort de
l'établissement pénitentiaire avec une
expérience
professionnelle ce contrat il est utile
pour l'ensemble de notre société parce
que mon obsession c'est la lutte
acharnée sans répit contre la récidive
et enfin ce contrat grâce à la
rémunération l'indemnisation des
victimes avec ce contrat les détenus
sont rémunérés 45 % du SMIC un
engagement gagnant gagnant pour le
détenu et l'entreprise où chacun y
trouve son intérêt je viens aussi pour
donner une chance à un nombre de gens
qui ont besoin qui ont envie de se
réinsérer de leur offrir une deuxième
chance donc de leur offrir un emploi de
les former de les embarquer dans une
nouvelle aventure pour ce patron
versaillais dont l'entreprise travaille
exclusivement avec le système carcéral
le travail se fait directement entre les
murs de la prison on travaille pour
l'industrie automobile aéronautique
cosmétique les imprimeurs on fait de la
sous-traitance voilà on fait l'emballage
du conditionnement l'étiquetages si
aujourd'hui la France compte 31 % de
détenus travailleur l'objectif du
ministère serait à terme d'atteindre les
%. voilà c'était donc la la visite du
garde desau don vous voez dans ce
reportage en effet comme vous êtes là
voilà on on va pas abuser de votre
présence euh alors en no le travail en
détention permet donc à une personne
détenu d'exercer une activité
professionnelle rémunérée euh pendant
son incarcération ça favorise évidemment
la réinsertion ça présente des avantages
on va parler pour l'entreprise et
l'objectif je crois du du ministère de
la justice c'est que 50 % au moins des
personnes détenu puissent exercer une
activité professionnelle rémunérée alors
voilà on va commencer par un premier
chapitre justement bah ce qui s'appelle
les détenus et l'entreprise alors on va
commencer par justement les les détenus
et l'entreprise al comment vous avez été
informé de de ce cette possibilité de
passer des contrats justement avec des
des personnes en détention Prin a ver au
mdeef 78 depuis un certain nombre
d'années et dans ce cadre là des
réunions sont organiser justement nous
offrant enfin nous nous présentant un
petit peu les différents panels euh et
tout ce qui peut y avoir tout ce qui
peut exister et donc au cours de ces
réunion il y en avait une qui avait été
organisée à l'époque à la maison d'arrêt
de bonarcy et c'est là où pour la
première fois j'ai mis les pieds au sein
d'une maison d'arrêt donc c'est vrai que
la première fois c'était assez
impressionnant mais du coup ça amène la
réflexion de se dire et pourquoi pas et
pourquoi pas donner une deuxième chance
à ces gens qui sont là pour ceux qui le
veulent à tout le moins et puis aussi
donner une chance de former des
personnes qui des fois n'ont pas eu la
chance d'avoir un un parcours de de
formation professionnelle et on en a
formé un certain nombre que d'ailleurs
après nous on a même réussi à embaucher
quoi au sein de au sein de l'entreprise
d'accord mais qu'est-ce qui vous a fait
sauter le pas si je peux dire ce qui m'a
fait sauter le pas alors on a on a fait
une première tentative dans les années
2010 2012 à la maison d'arrêt de
Versailles bien la préson des femmes de
Versailles bon pour diverses raisons
après bon nous on a eu on a arrêté et en
2019 face à la difficulté à recruter du
personnel euh qui est vraiment très très
compliqué sur le bassin notamment pour
tout ce qui est monteur et Technicien de
mesure physique euh j'ai repensé à aux
actions qu'on avait mené à la maison
d'arrêt de Versailles mais là en prenant
àâche auprès de auprès de boisarcy et
c'est ainsi que je suis rentré en
contact avec Madame Lorence et son
équipe et puis après avec Monsieur runif
et puis là ben on a commencé à
travailler à définir notre projet et
c'est comme ça qu'on a réouvert alors
après c'était ça c'était l'élément
moteur le deuxème aspect c'était aussi
on on avait une recherche de
proximité on voulait absolument trouver
quelqu'un de
proximité et puis ben côté RSE enfin je
veux dire moi je je cochais toutes mes
cases et notre volonté aussi d'aider les
gens dans dans le cadre d'une deuxième
chance é grimignon comment comment vous
êtes justement intéressé à cette
question et la question déjà moi je je
on a le droit pour tous en fait moi dans
la réinsertion c'est un droit pour tous
don vous avez vous pouvez vous retrouver
dans un milieu carcéral pour diverses
raisons ce qui fait que voilà et quand
monsieur cisset a démarché pour avoir du
travail de proximité et puis pouvoir
aider aussi le son son prochain comme on
dit en fait donc il y a eu il y a eu
cette prise de conscience avec Bois
d'Arcy et j'ai pu j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir rencontrer du personnel comme
Monsieur rinif ou monsieur cavalier à
l'époque qui ont pu m'introniser sur
Bois d'Arcy et et et me montrer un petit
peu le le tout le travail
potentiellement qui pouvait être fait
donc à partir de là il y a une
construction qui a été faite sur che
Prin savoir queles étaient les
possibilités de travail à donner à bois
d'Arc vous avez une première sélection
de du personnel qui est effectué par
Monsieur runif avec tout un encadrement
bien sûr et ce personnel je veux dire
que c'est un échange très positif très
favorable et c'est très humain donc
maintenant nous tous les produits que je
peux leur formuler et leur donner c'est
du produits de qualité qui nous sont
remis bien sûr que parce qu'ils sont
contrôlés sur place ils sont contrôlés
en fait chez nous chez brin puis
maintenant moi j'ai le le souhait de
faire une extension encore beaucoup plus
importante c'est d'arriver à avoir un
produit fini c'est-àdire que nous avons
une gamme de produits chez Prin pour en
détecteur et c'est de pouvoir avec une
nouvelle construction à Bois d'Arcy
développer ce produit entièrement en
faitcord et ça c'est avec une recherche
aussi de personnel qualifiés qui des
fois qui n'ont aucune qualification avec
ce que nous faisons en fait qui viennent
du bâtiment qui viennent de qui sont
comptables ou autrees mais qui avec une
formation qui est qui que je peux leur
donner et puis accompagné d'une autre
personne de chez pin où après on arrive
à formaliser tous ces produits don nous
avons besoin vous parlez de rapport
humain euh on va après venir justement à
la formation desus mais est-ce que vous
parlez avec eux de des raisons pour
lesquelles ils ont été en prison c'est
quelque chose qui c'est quelque chose
qui nous concerne pas je ne veux ça
c'est une c'est pour moi ce sont des
personnes lambda comme tout le monde en
fait je ne cherche pas à savoir qui ils
ont pu être avant je sais ce qu'ils sont
maintenant en fait hein voilà qu sont
leur capacités leur capacité il y a un
échange très favorable je ve dire tout
le monde se tutoit c'est comme si
c'était des collègues depuis 15 ou 20
ans que j'ai avec nous et c'est pour ça
qu' aussi j'ai avec le profil que qui
qui m'est donné avec Monsieur Rif on
peut il y a des possibilités de de
réinsertion en entreprise donc c'est
pour ça ce que disait monsieur CISS tout
à l'heure nous nous avons embauché deux
personnes qui étaient en situation de
sortie en fait don en semi liberté voilà
qui qui est intégré Bran le matin qui
qui est réintégrer le centre de boirtici
Le Soir et là j'ai encore deux personnes
qui postulent pour pour être chez pran
voilà oui c'est ça et comme disait alin
s d' une une qui a été embauchée
définitivement
hein deux qui sont en instance là qu'on
regarde tout ça c'est sur le profil
aussi que peut donner monsieur renif
déjà au départ sur les personnes
comme hier par exemple je suis présenté
au CRE pourir la candature de personnes
deç à P inégrer au moins de personnes
sur une nouvelle cha de de construction
que nous devons faire d'accord Isabelle
Laurence ça concerne quel type de détenu
justement on parlait tout à l'heure du
centre de détention de la maison
d'arrêt ça concerne les détenus qui sont
déjà jugés le travail concerne tout le
monde tout le monde on n'exclut pas même
ceux qui sont ce qu'on appelle en
détention provisoire donc tout tout
toute personne détenue qui souhaite
travailler parce qu' y a desensions
provisoires qui sont parfois longues
parfois en effet mais toute personne qui
souhaite travailler au moment où elle
arrive en prison elle a un entretien en
tout cas une infoc collective avec
l'ensemble de l'équipe donc ce qu'on
appelle ATF activité travail formation
et donc il postulent et ils sont et
elles sont reçues donc par le capitaine
et son équipe en entretien pour savoir
voilà un petit peu ce qu'elles ont fait
avant ce ce qu'elles voudraiit faire et
voilà donc on exclut
après comme comme on expliquait c'est
qu'il y a aussi un entretien maintenant
avec le concessionnaire donc à savoir
par exemple prendin ici aujourd'hui
c'est le concessionnaire c'est
l'entreprise l'entreprise en tout cas
qui est présente qui sont présentes on a
plusieurs entreprises présentes à bois
d'arie donc après il y a un entretien
avec le concessionnaire qui va dire bah
voilà cette personne m'intéresse plus
que d'autre et après on signera le le
contrat mais voilà on empêche personne
d'accéder au travail comment les détenus
reçoivent justement cette cette
possibilité pour eux de de travailler
alors on présente au moment de ce qu'on
appelle le parcours arrivant toute
l'offre de travail qui existe sur
l'établissement et ça ce n'est pas qu'à
boisarc c'est dans toutes les structures
pénitenties et nous à boisarci on a la
chance d'avoir ce qu'on appelle un canal
vidéo interne donc on a une chaîne
interne sur l'établissement et on on
diffuse en tout cas
des mais mais comment je voulais dire
comment ils le vivent est-ce que est-ce
que je veux dire quelqu'un qui arrive en
prison c'est pas forcément qu'on va
pouvoir peut-être lui proposer un emploi
est-ce que c'est est-ce que que ils
reconnaissent voilà que c'est peut-être
une chance pour eux est-ce que parfois
ils sont réticents alors il y en a qui
sont réticents mais on va pas les forcer
he le travail il est pas il est pas
obligé l'objectif c'est 50 % he voilà
c'est ça il y a des personnes qui ne
souhaitent pas travailler parce qu'elles
sont soutenues financièrement enfin par
l'extérieur par leur famille donc ils
souhaitent juste participer à des
activités socioculturelles et sportives
et d'autres elles ont besoin de
travailler parce que c'est un moyen
aussi pour elle d'exister en tant que
personne je rappelle quand même que la
prison en France c'est juste la
privation d'aller et venir absolument le
détenu reste un citoyen voilà je je le
rappelle fa Rapp ça parce que c'est
important le détenu est un simplement un
citoyen ce qu'on appelle empêché il est
pas déchu de ses droits civiques il a le
droit à la sécurité sociale il a le
droit de travailler il a droit à ce
nombre de choses et le travail lui
permet de sentir bah utile de se lever
le matin d'aller au travail de pouvoir
même envoyer certains de l'argent à leur
famille parce qu'il restent soutien de
famille donc la rémunération est
importante donc le travail est important
alors on va parler justement de de la
rémunération tout à l'heure euh Stéphane
runif justement alors donc votre votre
votre boulot si je peux dire votre
travail c'est d'aider justement à la à
la réinsertion des personnes qui sont en
détention et et donc de leur d'aider
cette réinsertion par le travail donc en
quoi consiste votre rôle justement
puisque hric Grimon le disait tout à
l'heure c'est vous qui sélectionnez un
peu les les les profils des des détenus
par rapport besoins ou demande des
entreprises oui tout à fait donc on
reçoit des demandes écrites par les
personnes détenu
euh ciblé ou non nous avons le service
général et aussi le travail en
concession donc on les reçoit on fait un
bilan de compétences donc euh comme
disait madame Laurence donc savoir
qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient fait à
l'extérieur des fois vous trouvez des
personnes expérimentées inexpérimentées
donc aussi on leur donne la chance euh
vous avez aussi des personnes qui
avaient aussi un cadre de vie euh à
l'extérieur qui était euh responsable de
de production et autres voilà on parle
aussi d'un grand vivier en fait il faut
voir aussi euh comme un grand pôle
emploi ouais voilà à à bois d'Arc on va
dire sur toutes les autres prisons et
vous avez euh le choix d'une sélection
sur différents types de productions
ciblé ou pas là sur Proengin on va un
petit peu favoriser les personnes qui
avaient quand même une expérience dans
tout ce qui est euh technologie ou et
qui était électricien
ouechnicien aussi des personnes aussi
qui n'avaient pas aussi euh d'expérience
dans ce dans ce métier-là on a par
exemple on a quelqu'un qui était issu
qui était taxi parisien et au cours du
temps est l'un des meilleurs opérateur
de prengin actuellement donc vous voyez
donc il y a un suivi un contenu qui est
proposé par prengin sur différents types
de tuto et des personnes nouvelles ou
inexpérimentées peuvent apprendre après
la sélection
euh il y a plusieurs critères en
fonction aussi des des concessions vous
avez des concessions qui font de
l'emballage classique donc pas forcément
besoin de d'une d'une certaine
compétence pour avancer donc pr engin on
va on va plus faciliter et apporter des
personnes qui ont déjà une expérience
après le le la particularité de pren
c'est que euh cet atelier là les
opérateurs sont en semi-autonomie parce
que le travail est apparté en début de
mois et en cours du mois s'il y a un
besoin euh il nous informe ou si ils
viennent sur sur le site et ils
récupèrent le travail à la fin du mois
donc les personnes sont quand même assez
responsabilisées sur le travail
minutieux que demande Prin est-ce qu'
pardon hein mais c'est une question qui
se pose il y a des outils pour
travailler BES moin donc des outils qui
pourrai servir éventuellement je sais
pas essayer de se libérer de de
s'évader est-ce que ça pose un un
problème particulier pour les pour bah
pour les les surveillants de prison et
non parce que en fait en début de
d'activité non je je pose la question
parce que c'est une question que les
gens peuvent se poser ou tout à fait en
début d'activité vous avez un contrôle
d'outillage donc tous les outillages
sont référencés et à la fin de
l'activité il y a le contrôlec après
aussi dans les différents entretiens
avec moi ou avec l'entreprise il y a une
prise de conscience qu'on qu'on fait
partager
la personne détenue euh elle est là elle
a demandé à travailler elle accède au
travail mais il y a des règles respecter
donc quand la personne détenue vous la
mettez dans des conditions où elle se
sent responsabilisée
elle fait aussi attention ça marche à ce
qu'elle fait ouais ça marche tout à fait
tout à fait euh Éric grimillon disait
tout à l'heure moi ça m égal de savoir
ce qu'ils ont fait avant ça ne
m'intéresse pas est-ce que c'est le cas
de de tous les toutes les entreprises ou
est-ce que il y en a qui pe le savoir
bah qui sont les qui sont les personnes
qui vont travailler pour pour elle et et
après toutune entreprise a accès à ces
données là ça reste
sur sur le domaine judiciaire
et confidentiel d'accord c'est ça reste
confidentiel absolument ok
Alban alors latiip c'est donc
l'association du travail d'intérêt
général et l'insertion professionnelle
euh racontez-nous ce ce que cette
association quel est son rôle al c'est
pas une association c'est un c'est un
service de compétence national par garde
des saut c'est une sorte
d'administration de mission qui a une
vocation simple c'est de créer les
conditions association excusez-moi notre
vocation c'est de créer une les
conditions d'une meilleure insertion
professionnelle du public de justice en
prison mais également ceux qui sont qui
font l'objet d'un suivi judiciaire en
milieu libre et tout ce public a un peu
des caractéristiques communes et tout ça
dans le but de lutter contre la récidive
d'accord c'est et on en parlera
peut-être tout à l'heure mais mais
évidemment le le enfin l'un des
objectifs de de ce travail en détention
bah c'est de permettre la réinsertion
plus simple des des détenus et
évidemment d'éviter d'éviter la ci c'est
c'est l'un des des buts avou enfin
exprimé par le Garde des S just c'est le
but absolu sachant effectivement comme
je vous le disais que la le public de
justice présente des caractéristiques
qui souvent l'éloignent un peu de
l'emploi ce sont des personnes qui ont
un état sanitaire global un peu plus
dégradé que celui de la la population
générale quand ils rentrent en
détenenstion quis sont pris en charge
par l'administration pénitencière c'est
souvent l'occasion de démarrer un
parcours de soins qu'ils n'ont pas eu à
l'extérieur c'est c'est un public aussi
qui qui a des difficultés d'Ax logement
qui a des niveaux de qualification très
faiible un peu plus de la moitié n'a
aucun diplôme pas même le brevet des
collèges donc voilà on essaie de prendre
en compte l'ensemble oui ça c'est c'est
important ça de dire ça donc a priori a
oui il y a très peu de personnes formées
qui qui il y a une une minorité de
personnes formées et une minorité de
personnes qui qui quand es rentrent en
détention avaient une activité
professionnelle après on a vu alors dans
l'histoire de de la détention des des
des des gens qui ont qui ont été
condamnés par souvent à des longes pe
qui ont qui ont profité pour faire des
études passer des doctorats c'est hein
c'est vrai que ça c'est c'est toujour
oui c'est toujours actuel enfin c'est
une c'est une donnée constante enfin qui
mais qui existe alors on va peut-être
passer à des questions un peu pratiques
alors que doit que doit faire une
entreprise pour engager un détenu à
l'incissé recruter voilà tout simplement
et se m contct se mettre en contact
forcément il faut se mettre en contact
avec l'administration pénitentiaire bon
après on définit comment on travaille
ensemble si c'est par concession ou il y
a un autre mode qui qui m'échappe là à
l'instant
euh c'était par par commande mais
concession par commande d'accord mais
maintenant c'est plutôt concession
c'est-àd concession ça veut dire quoi
c'est-à-dire qu'on met à disposition un
espace de production à
l'entreprise dans
l'établissement à titre gratuit
c'està-dire que l'entreprise ne paye pas
de n'a pas de bail ne paye pas de loyers
l'établissement
on détermine la surface de production en
fonction de la de la demande de
l'entreprise donc en fonction du nombre
d'opérateurs que l'entreprise souhaite
embaucher et puis ensuite on établit
entre nous un contrat de concession
alors justement qui signe le contrat
avec qui est-ce que c'est le détenu qui
signe avec l'entreprise alors le contrat
de concession pardon il est entre
l'entreprise et la direction
interrégionale et l'établissement enfin
d'ord l'établissement hein c'est pas
c'est pas directement le détenu et après
si le détenu il a ce qu'on appelle un
contrat d'engagement donc il a
l'équivalent alors c'est pas un contrat
de droit commun à 100 % mais il tend
maintenant le le plus possible à
ressembler à un contrat de travail et là
c'est entre la personne détenue enfin
l'opérateur l'entreprise et nous enfin
un représentant l'administration
pénitenciire d'accord donc oui c'est ça
c'est comme ça que que que se passent
les les les contrats
euh mais pour répondre à votre question
aussi plus de manière plus précise une
entreprise soit elle contacte
directement une direct tion de structure
mais nous avons au sein des directions
interrégionales des référents donc sur
le travail qui sont au courant de toutes
les surfaces disponibles au sein des
structures d'une même région et les
entreprises peuvent aussi également
contacter la ttig pour savoir un petit
peu ce qui existe enfin les surfaces
disponibles dans les structures
pénitentières sur le sol enfin sur le
territoire français ouis puis on parler
tout à l'heure avec Alb aussi des des
nouvelles des des des nouveaux métiers
justement vers lesquels peuvent se trou
des entreprises et et sur lesquelles les
les détenus sont formés euh une question
le travail se fait alors soit dans la
prison soit de la prison mais ça dépend
quoi du statut du détenu ou ça dépend
des besoins de l'entreprise ça dépend du
statut bah ça dépend du statut du détenu
enfin du régime enfin du régime
juridique sous lequel il est soumis
voilà parce que bon malheureusement ils
ont pas enfin nous celui qui a été qu'on
a embauché en semiberté il était avant
il a commencé à travailler c'est comme
ça qu'on l'a connu au sein de la de
l'atelier enfin la concession qu'on a
qu'on avait à baudarcy et puis après au
moment où il a pu bénéficier de la SEM
liberté on lui a proposé d'ailleurs un
autre poste qui n'avait rien à voir avec
ce qui nous faisait en milieu carcéral
au sein d'entreprise là où on a exploité
si je peux dire on a utilisé ses vraies
compéten professionnelle parce que
celui-là avait des compétences enfin une
vraie connaissance des vraies
compétences pro d'accord et par contre
l'autre qu'on a embauché lui c'est
pareil en fait il a continué à faire ce
qu'il faisait au sein de la maison d'
arrêt il a continué à le faire chez nous
quand il a été quand il a été libéré
d'accord et oui c'est ça c'est quand ils
sont en semi liberté ils peuvent aller
travailler dans l'entreprise revenir le
le soir
voilàement à l'établissement par contre
là ils sont très bien encadrés donc en
fait c'est vrai comment ça passe oui il
faut que enfin ils ont l'horaire de
départ et l'horaire de retour et si on
doit changer d'horaire parce que nous
c'est vrai que chez nous on travaille en
deux équipe l'équipe du matin et
l'équipe du soir et on se devait nous au
niveau administratif de prévenir
les services concernés à à la maison
d'arrêt du changement d'horaire pour
qu'il puisse puisse sortir et rentrer
sans avoir de de problème difficulté
particul d'c la rémunération c'est
important parce que je disat gagnant
gagnant et c'est gagnant gagnant pour
l'entreprise de ce point de vue là c'est
quoi 45 % du SMIC alors 45 % du SMIC
horaire brut oui horaire brut fixé par
la loi quel que soit le le travail c'est
fixé dans la loi c'est le seul minimum
de rémunération et c'est un se qui est
indexé au SMIC donc à CH minimum oui
minimum c'estàd que l'entreprise ne peut
pas aller en dessous de
45% si elle le souhaite en tout cas ce
n'est pas l'administration qui va
obliger à augmenter c'est
l'administration demande simplement à ce
que les entreprises respectent ce seuil
minimum de rémunération de 45 % du
smicroirbot le service général je sais
que c'est pas le sujet mais le service
général aussi ce qu'on appelle les oxy
leur rémunération également est fixé
dans la loi et égal général c'est quoi
ce sont les détenus qui travaillent pour
les établissements qui font eu de sortes
travaux pour les détenus en effet là on
parle plutôt des travaill en entreprise
mais il y a des travaux à l'intérieur
l'établissement qui sont accompl et pour
lesquels ils sont rémunérés également et
c'est le même type de rémunération ex et
la rémunération est un peu moindre
puisque ça dépend des tâches qu'ils
exercent mais elle est également fixée
par la loi d'accord c'est fixé par la
loi et enfin voilà c'est pas un travail
gratuit grat ce que vous disiez au fond
ils sont pas prévés de pouvoir
travailler et et de pouvoir de pouvoir
être rémunéré pour pour pour ce travail
euh
évidemment quand je disais oui contre un
gagnant gagnant on va parler évidemment
de la réinsertion avec Al tout à l'heure
mais pour les
entreprise c'est c'est quand même oui
pouvoir avoir des employés cooup un peu
moindre c'est important certes mais il y
a aussi un aspect formation et on le on
leur offre on leur offre la possibilité
d'être formé des fois des nouveaux
métiers et qui pourront exercer en
sortant puisque comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure monsieur man un certain nombre
quand même de détenus n'ont pas de
formation initiale où ne savent pas
enfin voilà n'ont pas de compéten
particulière là nous on le on leur offre
la possibilité d'apprendre un métier
c'est ça et évidemment quand vous les
engagez ce que vous faites pour deux
anciens détenus après c'est des salaires
ah ben après ils intègrent ils sont
traités de la même façon que l'ensemble
de nos salariés quoi le le celui qui
qu'on a recruté en
semiberté et qui avait d'autres
compétences professionnelles que celles
qu'il avait déployé au sein de la maison
d'arrêt il a été rémunéré en conséquence
par rapport à ses sa fonction quoi bien
sûr ou après ça n'a rien à voir je ve
dire moi enfin je on est dans la même
politique que ce qu'a expliqué Éric
grmillon tout à l'heure quoi enfin pour
nous ce sont des salariés lambda quoi je
oui grillon pour vous oui c'est ça c'est
des salar comme les autres quoi ah tout
à fait ce sont des collègues comme que
je côtoie depuis un certain nombre
d'années voilà ça fait partie de c'est
le cadre de l'ambiance en fait et vous
vous rendez à l'atelier de la prison je
m'y rends régulièrement comme pas plus
tard que qu'hier en fait parce que en
fait on a mis en place un travail
mensuel mais avait aussi avec un
contrôle que que je viens faire de temps
en temps pour regarder doné formmer
aussi par a des petites particularités
où entrreetemps il peut y avoir un
membre du personnel qui qui a été muté
qui est parti donc il y a un échange qui
fait voilà bon après on a des sur les
formations que j'ai pu donner on a des
références sur place aussi hein n j'ai
des opérateurs qui sont référent pour
Prange ce qui fait que toute personne
qui vient intégrer le le le le pôle les
opérateurs voulez dire quoi des les
opérateurs c'est le personnel détenu qui
est est làas voilà c'est pour ça c'est
un terme que j'aime pas j'aime pas dire
détenu parce qu'en fait oui je comprends
mais pour que les choses soient claires
pardon mais voilà donc toute personne
qui vient intégrer ce pôle travail pour
prend jein et déjà pris en charge par
Monsieur runif et son équipe et derrière
ça les référents que nous avons depuis
un certain nombre de mois à qui je
travaille en fait la formation est
permanente làbas justement Stéphane Rif
les les formations puisque c'est c'est
aussi votre votre travail de de former
les détenus euh est-ce que quelles sont
les demandes d'abord des détenus est-ce
qu'il y a des demandes particulières
est-ce que vous pouvez les former enfin
est-ce que à tous les métiers ou est-ce
qu'il y a des déjà des des des cases qui
sont prévues de formation on a un panel
de de formation qui est proposé au à
l'établissement euh ça va de avec les
les métiers du bâtiment de vous avez
aussi ce qui est proposé pour avoir un
capbp en mécanique auto h euh aussi en
électrotechnique vous avez aussi les
métiers de
employé commercial et qui sont les
formateurs pardon donc ce sont des des
professeurs issus euh deéducation
nationale d'accord voilà qui viennent
sur place don des cours théoriques et et
pratique d'accord et il y a un certain
enfin délai de formation selon les selon
les et FA et après le le le but aussi
c'est de à la fin de Ben l'obtention on
a quand même de bons résultats au niveau
destention des des résultats des
diplômes vous avez aussi le cursus qu'on
essaie de mettre en place par exemple
une personne détenue qui a eu son
diplôme en électrotechnique on essaie de
l'orienter après sur sur une concession
éventuellement éventuellement peut-être
prengin ou d'accord voilà justement donc
le chapitre de la formation
professionnelle et de la réinsertion euh
euh
euh est-ce
que c'est une question enfin je l'avais
un petit peu posé mais est-ce que vous
avez le le sentiment
que le le fait de travailler le fait de
sentir utile le fait d'apprendre a une
influence sur le moral des détenus tout
à fait ou à 100 % oui vous le constater
quoi enfin ouis c'est dire c'est dire
que c'est dé tenu j'allais dire plus
facile c'est pas c'est pas le c'est pas
le mot mais enfin qui qui au fond
profite de de de leur détention pour
apprendre un métier pour se réinstérer
enfin avec cette idée là quoi bah il
rentent dans un autre état d'esprit à
savoir la préparation de leur sortie
pour ceux dont les peines sont sont
relativement courtes comme disait Alb
man tout à l'heure la plupart des des
détenus qui rentrent en détention n'ont
pas eu de diplôme ont souvent quitté
leur parcours scolaire tôt hein donc
avant la TR donc déjà on a un
partenariat avec l'Éducation nationale
même si c'est pas le sujet aujourd'hui
on a des collègues de l'éducation
nationale qui sont au quotidien avec
nous pour pour enseigner au détenus et
donc certains détenus passent pour la
première fois enfin leur diplôme leur
premier diplôme souvent ils l'obtiennent
en détention que ça soit un DNB donc un
brevet des collèges certains le bac
certains Diplôme d'Accès aux études
universitairees certains même après des
licences et
cetera c'est des gens qui n'avaient pas
de diplôme oui enfin c'est certains
personnes arri en prison ne parle pas le
français et par et pas ce qu'on appelle
un diplôme de français langue étrangère
donc apprennent le français voir
d'autres langues et donc certains aussi
découvrent le monde du travail notamment
les plus jeunes je vais VO la surbois
d'Arc notre plus jeune il a 18 enfin nos
plus jeunes ont 18 ans et no plus l'âge
moyen pardon alors à Bois d'Arcy l'âge
moyen il est de 25 ans nos plus jeun nos
plus jeunes en 18 et nos plus anciens en
77 donc vous voyez il y a voilà mais le
plus gros le plus gros de l'accord c'est
25 oui donc c'est des jeunes quoi je ce
sont des jeunes et ce sont des jeunes
qui ont malheureusement pas connu le
monde du travail avant de rentrer en
prison donc être classé au travail et
leur premier rapport en prison enfin
découvert du monde du travail et ça leur
apprendre donc comme disait le capitaine
donc bah il faut se lever une certaine
heure faut être présent à l'atelier faut
justifier de ses absences faut respecter
donc le le cadre qui est donné enin
voilà voilà faut faut respecter les
objectifs de production qui sont fixés
par le concessionnaire voilà donc il
faut il faut bah voilà l'objectif nous
c'est de que le monde du travail
carcéral se rapproche le plus au mond du
travail extérieur puisque le jour où ils
vont sortir ils vont devoir aller
travailler et ils vont devoir se
confronter à ce monde-là qu' n'ont enfin
qui n'ont parfois jamais connu est-ce
que c'est parfois difficile oui oui nous
faisons du recadrage régulièrement oui
c'est vrai ça le le le principe de de
savoir vire savoir être tout tout ça en
fait ça fait partie aussi de de de la
réinsertion h
voilàpr parfis il faut rappeler les
règles les règles tout à fait oui donc
et après bon ben
effectivement généralement ça fonctionne
ou des fois bon après on peut mettre
aussi fa ça fonctionne pas qu'est-ce
comment ça se passe en fait maintenant
avec le contrat vous avez la possibilité
si c'est lié directement au travail
l'entreprise vous avez aussi le la
période d'cès d'ailleurs donc elle peut
mettre fin au contrat ah oui une période
d'ESS oui comme mois mois renouvelable
aussi en fonction aussi du type de
d'activité et donc si ça fonctionne pas
ben en priode déessès si c'est lié à
l'activité donc l'entreprise met fin à à
l'activité et si c'est dans le cadre
aussi disciplinaire Vous avez aussi des
des passages en commission de discipline
d'accord et donc le président de la
commission décide ou non de de mettre
fin à l'activité est-ce qu'on a un
pourcentage ou de la réussite ou de
l'échec de ce euh de ce
processus
euh à peu près un pourcentage de de
réussite on va à peu près je vous dirais
25 %. 25 % il y a quand même il y a
quand même un taux d'échec important
alors oui B après après ça dépend aussi
de la motivation aussi de de chacun ou
après c'est assez aléatoire aussi ouais
ouais h grimillon vous avez eu des
échecs aucun échec aucun échec parce
qu'en fait je travaille de la même
manière que je procède chez prongin en
fait il y a tout un aspect psychologique
aussi c'est de bien connaître les
personnes c'est d'avoir une approche de
de chacun c'est ce que j'appelle le
constituer une équipe en fait donc je me
rapproche très souvent de Monsieur réuni
pour avoir un petit peu de d'information
et puis je vois bien au moment où je
donne des du travail des informations
des précisions des formations le
comportement de la personne et je dois
dire que c'est tout est positif en fait
hein donc bien au contraire vous
évoqueiez tout à l'heure si ces gens ont
ont cette envie de vouloir travailler
bien sûr avant qu'il ait une mise en
place des des horaires chez à Bois
d'Arcy nous avions le personnel que
j'avais moi là-bas voulait travailler
travailler même le samedi il
travaillaient jusqu'à une certaine heure
le soir et ils avaient le besoin de
descendre et de vouloir travailler donc
il me réclamé sans cesse du travail
c'était vraiment un besoin donc il y a
eu une mise une mise en forme du temps
de travail PRS d'ement plus agréable
bien s sûr et c'est tout tout un échange
qui qui est complètement constructif en
fait c'est quoi c'est quoi justement les
horaires 7h30 13h30 7h30 13h30
l'après-midi non non c'est ce qu'on
appelle la journée continue la plupart
des établissements fonctionne comme ça
maintenant c'est-à-dire que les détenus
travaillent de 7h30 à 13h30 avec une
pause bien sûr au sein des ateliers et
comme ça l'après-midi non le weekend les
ateliers sont fermés sauf
exceptionnellement le samedi on peut si
le concessionnaire a
besoin
bah si si le cons a besoin une activité
de production excep enfin voilà un
besoin exceptionnel on peut fait ouvrir
les ateliers le samedi matinis et
d'ailleurs c'est vrai en période de
covid hein puisque enfin moi je je tiens
à le dire le grâce à l'atelier de qu'on
avait ouvert à à la maison d'arrê de
bonarc on a sauvé notre chiffre
d'affaires et notre notre production
l'année du covid puisqueon a un certain
nombre de nos sous-traitants qui avaient
dû fermer bon pour les raisons qu'on
sait mais euh la maison d'arrêt est
restée ouverte et là à cette occasion il
y en a eu un certain nombre qui ont
demandé à pouvoir travailler le samedi
effectivement et voilà ils nous ont ils
nous ont aidé à à pouvoir assurer la la
production de nos produits Alb il y a un
service de l'emploi pénitentiaire au
sein de l'agence hein oui
euh alors il enfin son utilité c'est
quoi c'est de de proposer des métiers
des formations en fait c'est c'est en
quelque sorte un concessionnaire en
régie donc on a nous-même aujourd'hui
plus d'une cinquantaine d'ateliers 54 ça
vous cré on crée des ateliers qui sont
alors qui sont dans les dans les
établisements pénitentièr qui peuvent
être à côté d'ailleurs de de
concessionnaire avec le l'objectif
d'avoir des métiers qui sont plutôt des
métiers qualifiés puisque il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de
concessionnaires qui font ce qu'on
appelle du façonnage c'est-à-dire de du
conditionnement de l'assemblage simple
de pièces et qui ne permettent pas
souvent d'acquérir des compétences qui
soient valorisables àextérieur nous on
est plutôt sur des méti qualifié la
confection le bois le métal tous les
tout le mobilier qu'on trouvé à
ministère de la est fabriqué en
détention ah ou absolument et par
ailleurs et par ailleursoui c'est bien
que est-ce qu'il y a des commandes
d'État d'ailleurs justementoui i on a de
nombreuses commandes d'état depuis
depuis la confection où on fait des
uniformes y compris de la pénitentière
du mobilier mais on s unes des gardiens
de prison sont fait par les prisonniers
absolument VO c'est c'est c'est ce qu'on
appelle économie circulaire ça quasiment
et on essaie aussi de se développer sur
des métiers un peu nouveau qui oui alors
il y a les métier du numérique notamment
parce que ça correspond plus aux
appétences d'un public qui est jeune en
moyenne en moyenne nationale c'est 31
ans en maison d'arrêt 31 ans donc c'est
c'est effectivement un public jeune euh
et puis parce que ça correspond aussi à
des m à des métiers en tension alors il
y a bien sûr le numérique on a ouvert
des ateliers de DAO de desinités par
ordinateur des ateliers de codage euh on
a ouvert aussi des des des des ateliers
qui répondent à des besoins enfin qui
sont là pour répondre à des besoins
d'entreprise comme des centres d'appel
on a des centres d'appel en détention
qui est une activité qui aujourd'hui est
réinternalisée souvent et relocalisée en
France c'estd quand on appelle voilà
quelques services c'est en fait c'est
des détenus qui répondent c'est ça hein
absolument absolument et donc ça
correspond à des métiers effectivement
sur lesquel il y a des forts besoins et
qui permettent aux personnes qui ne sont
qu'un temps détenus de retrouver
éventuellement ces métiers extérieurs et
d'être embauchés de façon près certaines
on a des des des chiffres des
statistiques sur le le nombre de détenus
qui
ont travailler en détenenstion et qui
retrouveent du travail non on on manque
aujourd'hui de donner consolidé on a on
a initié des études de d'impact qui qui
nous permettront d'ici 3 ans on va dire
d'avoir des des données à peu près
certaines aujourd'hui on je pourrais pas
vous donner un chiffre qui soit qui soit
qui soit fiable al est-ce que les vous
êtes aussi mem du mdaf vous le disiez
est-ce que les les entreprises sont
assez informé bien informé de cette
possibilité je pense très sincèrement
qu'il y a un manque d'information
évident euh pourtant le mdeef essaie de
faire de mener des actions
au niveau du Meline on en a amené on en
a déjà fait plusieurs dont une réunion
cette année mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un
manque d'information et je pense qu'il y
a une espèce de peur aussi enfin de
l'inconnu en fait personne ne sait ce
que c'est et c'est vrai que bah depuis
que je me suis encore investi un peu
plus que je ne faisais avant euh on a
échangé avec Madame Lorence et Monsieur
runif euh bon voilà on a organisé cette
année il y a eu au moins une réunion sur
le travail en milieu carcéral où on a
expliqué expqu bon sur cette réunion il
y a apparemment il y en a un ou deux qui
vont voilà qui ont pris contact auprès
de des services de la pénitence des
réunions ass enfin je sais pas si elles
sont récurrentes mais en fait vous
faites des des des des réunions pour
avec des chefs d'entrepris avec les
entreprises pour expliquer le
l'existence de ce travail non alors non
ce rôle appartient normalement à la à la
Direction interrégionale et au référents
travail la difficulté c'est que il y a
pas forcément des référents travail dans
toutes les les directions
interrégionales et puis il faut dire que
l'île-de-fance il y a c'est une des plus
grosses régions en tout cas pénitentien
parce que c'est là où on a le plus de
personnes incarcéré le plus
d'établissement donc en local enfin j'ai
envie de dire nous chef enfin en tout
cas chef d'établissement et moi-même bah
on voilà on essaie d'organiser ce qu'on
appelle des journées portes ouvertes
alors attention c'estàd qu'on on invite
des chefs d'entreprise voilà en tout cas
on invite des chefs
d'entreprise localonde
lo ce que disait monsieur ce qui
fonctionne le mieux c'est d'avoir des
concessionnaires qui sont dans le bassin
d'emploi ouais puisque c'est plus simple
en terme de logistique et CER bois d'Ar
voilà saincir quand j'étais à poisson on
travaille avec des entreprises qui à
poiss et pardon ça concerne il y a une
centrale poissie hein est-ce que ça
concerne les les desons
centralou bah boisi il y a plus de 80 %
des détenus qui sont occupés rémunérés
entre la formation professionnel et le
travail d'accord parce que sont voilà
ils sont moins nombreux ils sont là plus
longtemps donc c'est plus importantou
parce que c'est des enfin central il
faut expliquer c'est des longues peine
donc voilà des gens qui vont pas sortir
du jour au lendemain mais c'est une
volonté aussi locale de la direction de
d'essayer de chercher après moi on n pas
de de de comment dire de d'emploi enfin
j'ai une collègue maintenant qui est sur
sur la partie travail mais elle a pas le
elle peut pas faire on va je dire la
commerciale et faire le tour le tour des
entreprises donc on essaie de faire
venir ou alors on participe quand on est
invité par notamment monsieur CC dans le
cadre du MDF à des réunions spécifiques
pour parler du travail- ce qu'on sait
finalement parce que on parlait des des
centrales comme ça on peut supposer que
plus la détention est longue et plus la
réinsertion est difficile mais est-ce
que c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est un
lieu commun ça non c'est vrai c'est vrai
la la la prison amène une perte
d'autonomie qui est qui est certaine
donc plus vous restez longtemps en
prison plus vous êtes parfois éloigné de
la vie courante donc il y a besoin
d'comag sans doute plus fort
h là vous travaillez plutôt avec bois
avec boisar avec oui boisar
mais pourra travailler avec d'autres
établissements pénitencièes tout à fait
sans problème à partir du moment il y a
les structures pour pouvoir nous
recevoir aussi parce que on se construit
ensemble en fait BO c'est construit
aussi avec en tant que concessionnaire
Prin puisque il y a de modes de de
concessionnaire aussi parce que il y a
le concessionnaire qui est permanent
c'est-à-dire que vous y avez vous avez
un manager qui est sur place h nous on
est un concessionnaire permanent aussi
mais avec le manager extérieur d'où mes
venues un peu plus fréquentes sur le
mensuel mais bien sûr qu'on on pourrait
travailler aussi sur d'autres centres à
partir du moment ils auraient des
structures pour nous recevoir et puis
avoir le travail parce que là on on a le
souhait aussi de de pouvoir s'étendre
encore sur bois d'Arcis sur des sujets
encore plus importants donc voilà après
c'est tout un un système administratif
qui doit se mettre en place là alors
pour conclure je vais vous demander à
chacun si pour vous c'est un contrat
gagnant gagnant et m'expliquer pourquoi
alin CISS ah pour nous c'est un contrat
gagnant gagnant sur le plan bon
économique comme vous l'aveiez dit tout
à l'heure aussi par rapport à notre
démarche RSE et par rapport à l'aide
qu'on souhaite apporter aux gens de leur
offrir une deuxième
chance voilà pour moi c'est le c'est
c'est c'est très important et on y tient
beaucoup Alb écoutez je crois que c'est
un contrat triplement gagnant parce pour
la personne détenue qui effectivement
peut sortir de détension peut sortir de
sa cellule pardon a une rémunération
peut participer à l'entretien de sa
famille acquire des compétences pour
l'entreprise monsieur SC a dit et puis
pour la société dans son ensemble
puisque plus on baisse la récidive et le
et l'insertion professionnelle est un
des Levi importants mieux tout le monde
se
porteon c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant
puisque déjà c'est très riche
enseignement
humain et puis je suis quasiment sûr de
à 100 % de cette réinsertion puisque
dans le dans le programme qui proposé
les gens ont une formation et ils ont
uvré et être formé et pouvoir travailler
de la même manière en extérieur comme
ils l'ont connu sur ce centre de boisarc
en fait Stan Rif gagne gagnant pour moi
étant donné que la satisfaction aussi de
voir le parcours de la personne
incarcérée quel que soit le
motif l'accès à la formation le travail
et à la sortie possibilité d'avoir un
emploi Isabelle Laurence gagnant gagnant
puisque donc le comment dire ça
réhumanise aussi la personne détenu de
pouvoir travailler de sentir utile de se
rendre compte qu'elle a des compétences
et qu'elle a en capacité de pouvoir un
jour sortir et et puis de mettre à à
profit tout ce qu'elle a appris en
prison c'est intéressant justement
d'avoir les les de deux points de vue
hein de des gens professeur de de
l'administration pénidencière et puis
des des des des des entreprises et puis
je trouve que HC gréillon c'est
important parce que euh ce que vous
dites je je trouve ça très touchant
c'està dire que on a l'impression que ça
vous apporte complètement a complètement
ça m'a beaucoup aborté et je veux dire
que c'est je tiens à continuer dans ce
sens-l justement oui non mais c'est vrai
que humainement ça amène à réfléchir et
ça nous donne forcément une autre vision
de de d'une partie de la population quoi
c'est clair merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à T les ça Aniss si des
entreprises sont intéressées évidemment
par le par la voix du du MF par exemple
peu cont il y a aucun problème je répond
tout
merci infiniment merci
[Musique]
merci